well most the time most times when I'm
asked that question it deals
specifically with legislation what's the
biggest thing he ever did in that
respect and there are quite a few and I
try not to select any perhaps
illustrative was the major clean air
bill that I was a principal supporter
and author of in 1990 that was a very
contentious bill took years and years of
effort and a very long legislative
process and I I told her a lot of my
life to it that probably in legislative
terms was I don't know if it was the
most important but it was the most
comprehensive and major bill outside of
that I tend to talk about two things
first my work in Northern Ireland I
spent a total of about five years
chaired three separate sets of
proceedings I wasn't there for five
years non-stop by coming and going and
but for the most part I was there for
long periods of time during that stretch
and we just in the past month have
celebrated the 10th anniversary of the
so-called Good Friday Agreement the
peace agreement which resulted from one
of the negotiations which I cheered that
was very significant I I like Northern
Ireland I like the people I like the
place I still go there quite a bit I
serve as the Chancellor of the Queen's
University in Northern Ireland which is
a large institution of higher learning
there and so that takes me back and
other in other capacities I go back
probably three or four times a year and
I like to take my children here to give
that young children give them some sense
of what was important in my life the
other thing that I I spent a lot of my
time on and then I'm most proud of is
when i left the senate i created a
scholarship program for needy students
from maine started small
I got started in a funny way I had
raised money in preparation for
re-election and then I decided not to
run and so I wrote to every contributor
and I said you can have your money back
if you want it but if you leave with me
i'm going to use it for scholarships and
about half took the money but i could
have bought half left it with me that
got us started and I've since been that
was 13 years ago and I've spent a great
deal of time in the intervening 13 years
raising money and we now provide a
scholarship to graduate from each public
high school in Maine 130 of them each
year so we have a lot of kids have gone
through the process and I spent a lot of
time at it and it's very heartening to
see it because i myself as i mentioned
earlier in the interview I wasn't
certain how it's going to go to college
my parents had absolutely no money my
father wasn't working at the time and I
got a lot of help from a lot of people
some scholarship assistance a lot of
work effort Bowden college which I went
to a great institution to which I owe
much of what I've been able to do in
life they helped me out with a lot of
job so I kind of worked two three four
jobs all the time while i was in school
and it not only helped me get through
school but it taught me I think a good
work ethic so the scholarship fund means
a lot to me I meet with these students
each year and I see in a lot of them
where I was at the time uncertain
insecure don't really know what you're
going to do with life but there's a
potential
you